because they're used to being down they're
not happy obviously nobody is but you know
what it's really hard to play this game
when you're chasing it all the time loose
in front of the goal good save there off cop
and a race there after it when Justin Bailey
Bailey's got it Bailey in penalty coming to
Detroit y dogged dogged dogged checking right
there by San Jose perfect sharks power play
here 53 seconds the first passed in front of
the goal couple of waack by hurdle big Sav by
whoo big stop with hurdle right there Addison
gets it in down low purposely sent Deep by L to
Brink it Petri to kanaine oh and a save made by
Blackwood Carri back in by granin puck
knocked down loose in front of the net
good save there who saw a piece of that
again on William sometimes you get yourself
caught in a position like that but uh you
would want to see the puck personally off
the draw loose but scars right from
the face off toon jams it in it's one
nothing in front of the goal tender Mike and
cson who 64 220 just basically won that battle
yeah he just the puck got squirted back and
he just out battled them and the the San Jose
defenseman got a caught up into his foot and
he couldn't get a handle on it and uh he just
dug it out right there and popped it in and
uh just a good effort and going to the net
well that's a one nothing lead for Detroit
and probably San Jose thinks they should be
up in this game Mike Vernon's right big body
oh he got surprise sends one to the goal and
it finds its way through the Pearly Gates and
it's two to nothing he was going for a line
change down right by the blue line by the
Red Wing second uh door I think it hit the
goenda hit r m we'll have to see another angle of
that hard to tell but it looks like the way the
goal tender went down at a change direction for
sure yeah what a good fortune goal that is
for Detroit so boy that fourth line for the
Red Wings with ction that energy oh they
got another another deflection it's three
nothing whoa
again oh there's the sitick it's it's
rash M they'll be looking at this one he's
6'6 it's up high for sure that's okay though
but it's crossbar height it's crossbar height
not shoulder and he's got high shoulders
San Jose called timeout wo Lin's got it
Lin to fabric in for shro check back very
scar Raymond oh my God the floodgates have
opened smoke what a nice play by Sarat nowhere
else to go either and an empty Netter for Raymond
to make it four nothing and blackwood's gone
and that's too bad and the sharks are going to
be short-handed un Sportsman likee conduct
penalty to Mark Edward blasing the veteran
defenseman that's very poor four checking on
a power play Lin went back in front knocked
away eek and boy the sharks are lamenting the
chances they've missed as hurdle scores he gets
a short-handed goal that H got a piece of but not
up up and San Jose on the board trailing by three
now on a shorty forward CAU there's a bounce
off the skate and two Sanel they guys go away
they take the pass away by gos bear that's what
you're supposed to do leave the shooter to the
goal tender he's looking sort of Faking it and
so they can score and they had chances tonight
so too much time left to count them up here they
come again and it's zland who's right in he scores
it's four to2 warn you man well that's that'll be
the end of the four forwards on the power play I
think cider he blew a tire back at the Blue
Line right there the puck took a bad bounce
and uh they're gone great shot oh my godo's mad
but that that kid made a heck of a shot Fabian
zland now has his eighth goal a career high wow
and tied but made 33 saves Kane gets ridden to
the boards by ohuk lead pass onto the stick of
BL in front of the go they score it's Nico Sturm
makes it 4 to three the penalty at expired and
the Sharks playing loose now absolutely stunned
to this Red Wing team got 19,000 people
my goodness so now you got a game boy oh
boy what a crazy output offensively BR put it
in back of the net in on the P check goes fer
and finishes his check as the glass rattles
as he hits oh here come the Sharks again ster
he scores a tie game Nico Sturm with two goals on
the season two goals here in the second period tie
unbelievable yeah a lot of Defense being played
holy smoke eight goals here in
the second period of these two
teams wild that is wild wild
wild quick shot from Addison gets
knocked down wman into the fabri
to Raymond SC Delan lurin it's 5 to
four oh his sixth goal the past six
games Kevin larin's here enjoying that one oh
yeah what a what a setup first ball to Raymond
and then back to Lin who just ripped it I
mean there wman fabry and over to Lin from
Raymond and bingo you got a 5-4 game was 640
to go yeah San Jose can't call timeout there
they used it earlier when 3 nothing yeah Dave
Quinn was giv it to his team well worked in
the long run for him at least till now back
to the line it comes to granin took the shot
do white re they score wow hurdle bangs it
in to tie it up 55 as the Sharks bench is
elated Face Off safe there's
a med bunch of humanity a Kick
Back by hurdle himself there's
grin with the shot goes off the
backboard I wonder if that's where
he was going too could be I I'd have
to see a different angle to
just try to figure out he was
yeah back for Lucas Raymond tough
one to handle loose Buck L coming
back but it's edelin who's in the clear
penalty coming up sett and of course
they score branlin gets the winner for
San Jose they beat the Red Wing six to
five well three on three Lin toe pick
nice play by San Jose and what they
couldn't convert in the first 20 minutes
and they had plenty of chances they found
a way in the second and here in the third to
find just enough finish to finish the red WI